councilwoman Victoria Seaman speaking
out about a lawsuit that she filed
against both the city and fellow Las
Vegas councilwoman Michelle Fiore
Madison Kimbrough spoke to seaman today
and heard from others involved
[Music]
I was assaulted by councilwoman Fiore
and again it there was never any
accountability for it and things just
became more and more and more aggressive
Las Vegas councilwoman Victoria Seaman
taking action Monday filing a lawsuit
against fellow councilwoman Michelle
Fiore for battery and assault this after
an incident that left Siemens hand
injured with a broken index finger
according to the lawsuit in January of
2021 councilwoman Fiore grabbed
Victoria's hair from behind yanking her
head back and throwing her down to the
floor inside of City Hall and now after
a year of trying to get things resolved
Seaman believes filing a lawsuit was her
last option I have been trying to get
changes in policy so this doesn't happen
to anyone else
I don't ever want somebody to be
assaulted it's even telling eight news
now that she confided in mayor Goodman
for help she says her claims were then
dismissed and instead the mayor advised
her to resign the city also being held
responsible for not releasing video
proof of the incident Victoria says
she's seen that video but believes the
city destroyed it to cover up the
evidence the city stating Monday that
they will not comment on pending or
ongoing litigation and as for Michelle
Fiore her spokesperson released a
statement stating that this lawsuit is
an attempt to stop Fiore from winning
her upcoming election quote we look
forward to the truth coming out as soon
as possible
so in that lawsuit Seaman is seeking
money for medical bills along with other
damages and she also wants fiori to
resign and she wants additional safety
measures put in place at City Hall so
that incident like these don't ever
happen again